[Music]
yeah fun with your new best buddy hey
that's your thought your dad likes me
you did it idiots your whole life he was
right about one thing I am married to a
stud yeah I felt so bad about selling
you out I thought I would maybe make it
up to you mm-hmm wait wait I can't I
mean I want to but I'm not supposed to
you for the next three days oh that's
right I forgot mm-hmm all right well
guess I'll just read a little and then I
don't know go to sleep
really that's what you're sleeping in oh
you want me to get off all right well
then pipe down and let me read my comic
book I mean I I know what you're doing
is please stop oh listen to this BAM Wow
take that Batman
ami there's something out here just wrap
it under a cop and I'll be there in a
minute
I'll try but it's Leonard
what what is he doing here I told you if
we left pizza on the counter we to track
something oh hey guys
sorry I used my kids needed a place to
crash is everything okay yeah I had to
give her the apartment my wife kept
trying to have sex with me been there
why are you trying to avoid having sex
we just did it three months talking